My name is Jean-Pierre Lehman. I am concerned
with International political economy. I am
the business school in Switzerland. My nationality
is French. I think that the question, or the
opposite question depends on how long the
prices [inaudible]. In other words I think
that the due critical situation in East Asia
is fragile as we know it[inaudible], but really
by and large over the course of the last two
decades it has been managed reasonably well.
With things, for example, Taiwan, China, different
things about disputes of the South China Sea.
The exception of course is North Korea where
there have been; we've maybe seen this scenario
evolving which might indicate the demise of
that particular regime. However if the crisis
persists particularly at the very high level
of unemployment, then I think we could be
talking about [inaudible] and political risks
of a considerable vantage.